foreign
next in Columbus Ohio hi Julie welcome
to the uh Ramsey Show
hi thank you I appreciate you taking my
call sure how can we help
so my husband and I are working on the
steps and we are on step two
um and now we're ready to we differ a
little bit in our viewpoints as far as
what we should do next so we're both 50
years old and I want to focus any extra
money on any of our debts or all of our
debts the credit cards and such and he
has just started a job that now has the
opportunity for some retirement funds
and he's never he does not have any sort
of retirement or pensions up to this
point
so he wants to focus all the extra money
he can into building the retirement fund
for himself okay so you didn't really
tell us accurately then you said my
husband and I were wanting to work the
baby steps because the truth is you are
wanting to work the baby steps he's not
yeah you guys are not on the same page
right yeah you're wanting to be baby
step two everything in on getting out of
debt because when you get out of debt
then you've got plenty of money to put
money into retirement and yeah you've
got some catching up to do at 55 but you
can do it but the fastest way to do it
is get out of debt so you're ready to do
it he's wanting to do his plan
yes hey so I guess
I'm sorry go ahead are you guys
combining your money the way you talked
about
your retirement you said hey I heard you
say his retirement and his I just want
to see where you guys are in that area
and so basically he is giving me some
towards the bills at this point and I'm
finally getting him
um with the idea of you have to let me
take over because he struggles with it
nope so both are wrong you know you're
both wrong yeah
you guys need to overhaul this entire
situation because the fact of the matter
is you're not on the same page you want
to do this he wants to do something else
you guys are not sharing your money
you're on separate game plans
thing one is
getting United on just marriage which in
this case involves your money and I'm
wondering for you if you were to speak
to him and say hey I talked to some
Knuckleheads on the radio today and they
said that we need to combine our
finances that's step one what would he
say to that
and what do you say to that
I'm I'm game for it um we had done that
in the past and
um we we were fine with it I managed
paying the bills I kept him informed of
everything
um he was starting a new job he has kind
of gone a bit overboard on spending and
opened up a bunch of new credit cards
and I do feel like he's just gotten
embarrassed as to where he is at this
point
where he can't handle it yeah when I do
stuff stupid It embarrasses me too so I
understand
yeah yeah because this I mean what he's
doing is wrong of course he's
embarrassed of course he feels foolish
because he's been foolish
that'll make you feel foolish being
foolish I've done it I know
so yeah so here's the thing
let's back up three steps like we said
and like Jade said and reset so re a
proper okay number one the advice we're
giving you is not Theory we've done this
with millions of people and have led
people to become Millionaires and retire
with dignity with a paid for house let's
just say that's the goal okay
let's say that by 70 you're a
millionaire and you have a paid for
house that's our goal what is the
fastest right way
to get there
okay that's a question you and your
husband both need to answer
now we have proven
by teaching and walking with thousands
and millions of families now that the
fastest right way to get there is a
process that we call the baby steps
where you first save a thousand dollars
and baby step one baby step two is you
pay off all of your debts except your
home and because your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
when you give it all to Ford Motor
Company and MasterCard you don't have it
anymore they do
and so you have to stop giving your
money away to these idiots that are
taking your money but you gave it to
them so you have to stop it that's
called debt reduction right we're
getting out of debt now when you don't
have any debt payments but your house
anymore that'll feel pretty good won't
it ask him that and I'm asking you that
Julie that'll feel good won't it say yes
yes yeah and the credit cards that he
just took out we're going to have a
little plastic surgery Party by
candlelight tonight
chop those puppies up
a plastic to me at Julie's house okay
now once we're out of debt we build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then we start saving 15
percent of our household income into
retirement if you do that if you follow
that how much debt do you have
not counting your hands right
not counting the house we're at about
121 000. on what
um credit cards and a truck payment for
him how much do you owe on his truck
20 000. and what's your household income
well a hundred thousand okay
got a lot of truck
yeah you got it now so part of this is
this 55 year old little boy is going to
grow up and be a man now and put his
future in his sights and not his weekend
that's part of what's going on here this
guy the way the way you have described
him in this call he just goes and does
whatever the flip he wants as if there's
no consequences
and then he's embarrassed okay so now we
got to stop this and we got to undo a
bunch of it now then the last part of
this whole story is the two of you are
going to decide together every month
before the month begins on paper on
purpose where every dollar is going to
go to accomplish the goals in those baby
steps so that we can retire with a paid
for house and a million dollars
and if we are saying that's the goal and
whatever we've got to do to get to that
goal that means we're going to sell
everything in sight we're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant unless
we're working there we're not going on
vacation because we're broke people
we're 55 years old and 120 000 in debt
and no money and scared about retirement
and we're going to do something about it
and that's just who you become and the
two of you together join arms and say
we're going to be grown-ups it's not
thank God it's Friday oh God it's Monday
it's we're going to retire in 15 years
from now with some dadgum money
because we changed our lives now if
you're ready to do that Julie I can help
you that's what we do but if you're
going to keep playing around playing
footsie with this and he's going to keep
running around like a weekend little boy
Huey Lewis in the news
living for the weekend not gonna work
for me I can't help you but if you want
to do all this stuff we'll put you
through Financial Peace University you
hold on you can tell Austin if you want
to do it we'll pay for you to go through
the class you and your husband that I
just picked on this is the Ramsay show